keep in mind so her your parents don't
know anything yet
so did they just throw a modeling man
so when we got there i remember going
into the basement
for one don't say that you just came out
of prison a few months ago
yeah that's not applause have you ever
messed up your life so
bad that you've wondered if god can even
get you out of it find out on this
episode of
led live
[Music]
welcome back to led live you guys are in
for a treat today because we have some
amazing guests and an amazing story
justin and julie thank you for joining
our show light exposing darkness
um you know who doesn't have a colored
past right
yeah this story this though is a neat
story because
um i just feel like uh the little amount
that i've been able to
interact with you guys and and sort of
hear where you guys came from
just to see how god can transform your
lives in a mighty way
set you on a path of just you know
different than you would have ever
imagined and so i'm excited to hear
about
uh what you guys are are gonna share
today but um
let's just start back from the beginning
let's uh dive into this
ah yeah probably the beginning um
so i grew up um in a christian home
and uh where god was the center on a
weekly basis um
you i grew up in just a very casual
go to church maybe on holidays that was
about it type of a thing
um we had a bible didn't read it a ton
so limited knowledge very limited yes
spiritual things
the lacking of relationship that that
part i didn't understand growing up
and me i always had a calling ever since
i could have thoughts in my mind i
always had a calling in my heart for
like some type of ministry
um but uh as a little rougher on the
edges i did share with you that
we never moved but we went to 11
different or i went to 11 different
schools
um so yeah so same town 11 different
in the area no we had to kind of we had
the broadband
yeah wow i know one of the schools in
eighth grade
uh so my mom actually swapped out with
this other mom they drove us there four
days a week there's an hour and 20
minutes
they're hours and 20 minutes back wow
and um we went there four days a week
the fifth
uh the fifth day we ended up getting our
homework and then doing it at home
so we did that for my whole eighth grade
year
wow and uh yeah so i was a little bit
rough around the edges i had a calling
in my heart for ministry but uh
like i said i had some challenges
growing up so what kind of things would
would get you kicked out of school i
mean i can't even imagine um
definitely adhd things did you light on
fire
so uh yeah i was i was i was always like
a real intense type person
so um anytime i tried to play sports
with people or do this or do that they'd
end up in the hospital
i felt bad i felt bad like i really
because i felt deeply so i'm like i feel
bad
like every time i'm playing like
somebody's getting hurt and then i'd get
mad
and um so at one point i think it was
like in
third fourth grade i pretty much just
hung out with the girls so i learned how
to double dutch i learned how to
you know twirl on those bars and all
kinds of other stuff so play with the
boys and be like we don't want to play
with him
so yeah so yeah that was one of the
things
you know growing up so but um
yeah then when we met um
man so growing up when i i went to all
these different schools
and uh finally ended up
getting in the wrong group and i think
many of us you know have gotten
into the wrong group at some point
especially in high school
and you have that story as well and
because of my personality being really
intense you know most people like have
stopped points and i'm just like well if
i'm doing this let's go
you know and so i went from like zero to
60 within a short period of time and
from
right around when i was like 17 years
old i
i started i remember coming back i i
came back from a private school which
was
six hours away so i was at the dorms uh
during that time
and i came back from a private school
and i was with a friend of mine and we
both grew up in the church but
uh you know he went to a public school
and he handed me a cigar that was one of
the first uh
again initial things he's like oh
they're not bad you don't inhale
yeah yeah yeah you know so how long did
that last they went from cigars the
cigarettes
to you know and same thing that i went
to marijuana and then you know
all that and then when i got involved in
the group of gentlemen i was involved
with
uh it really exponentially got
um rapidly bad
if you will so so are your parents aware
of this
and then you know are you kind of
getting in trouble to the point where
they're they're like okay
we we need to ship this kid off to a
boarding school is that kind of why
you've got
well uh so i mean i got literally i got
expelled from schools and my parents
bless their heart they're trying to do
their best
um you know so i went to one school you
know i had i had ed i had all the
all the letters in the back of my name
except it wasn't doctor phd it was all
ed ld
you know adhd and uh so i had all those
letters but um
yeah they were trying to do the best
again i got expelled my dad said hey go
to this
my freshman year um i went to academy
and i i loved it there i i only got
suspended three times but then the
fourth
so then when i went to go to school so i
didn't actually get kicked out i did get
suspended three guys but
uh so when i went to go there the next
year it was my freshman year i thought
it was a pretty good year
and they says well take a break and i'm
like me take a break or you take a break
i didn't really understand the take a
break part so that's when i went to
another school she was six hours away
and my dad's just like instead of
sending me to public school he's like
well just
go here try it you know if you don't
like it then you
come back trying to keep me away from
public school because
that wasn't a good place for me so i
tried it for a semester and then i
finally came back
and that's when i came back you know i
started regressing rapidly
um to the point where you know i was
you know i was going out uh i did a
bunch you know i
was burglarizing places four or five
days a week
um you know burglarizing them for the
means to get like money
to support your soul you know yeah and
my justification was
businesses okay i'm gonna go to
businesses they're you know it's just
a brain yeah it's how the brain works
but you know that's the deceptiveness of
sin you know i'm like okay they're
insured you know i'm just gonna go
and start it off being that age it was
cigarettes you know so i'd go in i'd hit
places at
2 300 cartons of cigarettes you know so
i had that and then
you know how do you get that many
cigarettes like i mean not to give any
ideas out there but is it was it a gun
point
robbery or was it like well no
businesses
um after hours after hours yeah after
hours type thing i'd go in
and uh you know
did a lot of things like that you were
able to get in after they're closed
correct so we get in after they're
closed and um
was it the things that you were after in
the business or it was just the
experience of actually
stealing was it i think i think honestly
you know so
so i had the gentleman that you know it
was
a type of a gang that i was in so i was
like okay well i wanted to rise up
quickly
i wanted to be somebody important you
know i'm doing all this stuff i'm
getting from my guys
you know so i'd get this i'd get that
they'd sell it you know i'd go through
and
you know uh we're talking
i mean we're teenagers so we're anywhere
from
15 to 18 years old are most of the guys
that are doing this and it's crazy when
i think about it now right
but i mean that was reality and it
having a christian upbringing are you
feeling guilty at all for any of this i
mean where are you like mentally in this
state
that's probably one of the saddest
points
because i knew you know i knew truth
and uh you know and i feel bad even like
thinking back at it now but i
intentionally did things to separate my
conscience
so i would listen to music that would
sever my conscience i would do things to
sever my conscience
so i wouldn't have to feel the things
that i knew
you're quieting it wait you mean that
media does have an influence on your
brain wow okay
hey did you even know that it's a
surprise
i've i heard a testimony of a dude who
was getting into a gang and he said like
you had to like kill somebody like an
initiation he said
we would drive around the block and i'd
just be listening to rap music and all
this gangsta thug and all that stuff
and he had to do that he like he
couldn't just go up to somebody and kill
him or rob him or whatever
he actually wrote around the block and
he's listening to this over and over
this gangster stuff pumping him up and
then he'd go do it
and that's how he did it i knew a guy in
the military and um
he was special ops and so naturally i
was like so have you killed anyone
you know and he said oh yeah and and he
said the first time that he did it he
felt
terribly sick to his stomach i mean he
went back laid his head on his bed and
just could not get
that person's face out of his head it's
the second time not so bad
third time it's kind of fun fourth time
you're looking for it and you want to
like take them out so
real quick you can sear your your um
your conscience and
if you keep going down that path you
know you end up with zero conscience
there was a rapper who was feeling bad
in a way because people wanted
them to make that kind of content dark
and
gangster type music and he's like no
because that puts me in a bad state of
mind for
days i don't want to do this anymore and
if it's doing it to him imagine those
listening to it yeah yeah you know
what happened so with me you know as
things were progressing it started with
businesses
and then started like okay well drug
dealers they're bad even though i was
doing the same exact thing you know what
i'm saying
i'm good i'm like well they're bad so
you know
you started getting to the point and
praise god the lord
uh removed me before i got to that point
but just before i got arrested
um thankfully i was i was making plans
to
kick indoors and you know basically you
know steal the drug steal
the money and the mindset was the only
way not to get caught is not to have
anybody left i mean that was the mindset
and you think
how dark that goes and how quickly that
goes sure
and you know i remember uh we ended up
me and a buddy of mine i was on a
motorcycle
me and a buddy of mine went to this
gal's house her name was tony
and uh we started talking she didn't
believe in god well
all the knowledge and everything i had
back in we just started
talking you know and as these things
started coming out
the holy spirit started to convict my
heart and
they went outside and i i remember i was
froze in the chair
all these thoughts running through my
head and i'm just you know
and they came back on in i went outside
i went up by the highway
and my buddy came out and he said what's
going on i said i just got all these
thoughts in my head
you know he's like i just don't think
about him but i knew i said
but that's what satan wants me to do you
know what i'm saying so there was this
battle
so we ended up driving to a friend of
ours gravesite is one of the first
deaths at that time i was 17 years old
and we ended up going to a friend of
ours gravestone we were there
and you know just thinking i mean i had
a duffel bag of guns
i had this is what we had on us you know
so i had a duffel bag of guns
and miscellaneous things visiting this
grave site and
all these things going on in my head and
he says well i have a pastor in town
that i used to go to
as a kid let's call him his eight nine
o'clock at night you know
i'm like okay so uh he called him and uh
the pastor says yeah i'll meet you guys
so we ended up going um to the pastors
they
talk about come as you are i mean right
he had no clue but i got a big
i'm coming in with a duffel bag full of
guns he didn't know what was in it or
anything
but um you know we go through and the
pastor started saying hey
you know uh about repentance and you
know say hey
you're forgiven when you ask for
repentance if there's things you can
make right that's fine my buddy's
getting into it like oh yeah
i'm thinking i'm 17 years old so this is
the same guy that said ignore those
thoughts
correct and now he's getting into it oh
wow and i'm thinking
i'm too far gone 17 years old
yeah and and you know i look bad i'm
like 17 years old
totally you're like you're just too far
going yeah that's
it you know i'm glad my buddy's getting
into it but
there's no hope for me you know and um
i i felt like i just got to get away
well
praise the lord through multiple
situations
i ended up on a high-speed motorcycle
chase and a bunch of different things
but i ended up getting arrested two days
later
as i'm running from the cops this sounds
crazy but as i'm running through the
cops we ended up
crashing the motorcycle um i
i grabbed the bag it was light so i'm
like oh crap you know
knowing things that you know a lot of
the guns fell out and i didn't know how
many were left
and i started running as i run to hear
the k-9 unit i ended up running
maybe five miles i went through all
kinds of you know lakes and streams and
everything else because i'm an intense
person so i'm just like okay
not easy to catch as long as they keep
going don't be okay
so um after going through all this stuff
uh they end up getting my body but after
going through all this stuff
um it started to get light i'm like oh
shoot
well uh i got to a friend of mine's
house and i'm
sopping wet this is the beginning of may
it's cold outside
um and i end up going through going in
their garage
stripping down into you know just my
basic clothes went in the back of the
vehicle they had a towel and i just kind
of wrapped up
and i woke up to the starting of the
vehicle
it was actually her mom driving in the
work
so i'm in the back just thinking i'm
kind of like oh
you're in the vehicle
and here we are we're driving at the
town i'm just thinking like
okay what do i do you know so she ends
up going all the way like in the town
and goes into work never knew i was in
the vehicle
yeah does she know to this day she does
know that
we talked about it and yeah but what a
freaky thing
seriously you know so anyways
didn't have shoes i had this towel you
know it's in may
there's rainbow track sexy i took the
tall wrapped it up put it over my feet
you know i mean
so anyways so that i you know took the
tall wrapped around there tried to just
you know because i didn't
have a lot of gear and then uh
you know went to railroad tracks i'm
saying i was on the north side i said
i'm going to south side of town where
some of the guys were blah blah blah so
even though i'm
running and all this as i was running i
knew it was over
i knew i was caught you know what i'm
saying and that to me was only a matter
of time
yeah you know they know too much about
you correct they're gonna correct
so i'll find you you know and as i went
through you know
as i was going to the south side of town
um
i ended up hearing sirens i was running
and i went over this bridge
where there was a railroad track bridge
and then there's a car bridge and then
there's a river why are we went through
so many rivers i said well that's the
most
inconspicuous way if you know i'm tired
you know like i'm gonna go across here
hopefully not if so
like i'm just you know so i go across it
i see a
cop going through i duck down he goes
around the corner as soon as he
goes around the corner i run up the side
and here is
you know perhaps wherever and then you
know i ended up freeze and i was like
yeah i'm done
you know wow um but that that whole
dynamics the lord was
because i wasn't at that time able to
remove me
the lord was removing me you know that
that's a good point because
sometimes god allows us to get in
trouble i mean you just think of the
children of israel right they got
removed from that space and brought to
babylon that wasn't god's intention
necessarily to have his people go
through that experience but
it was like they wouldn't listen and
they wouldn't get to to a place so he
said
look you're gonna have to reap the
consequences and sometimes it's those
consequences
as much as yeah it saves us you could be
sitting here right now because
you got caught he can work all things
together for good you know
no matter what situation you go through
he can turn that plan around
wow and my my older brother carl even
said one of the things that he said he
said
you know did you kill anybody because
you know there's a difference
if you you do crimes and different
things and don't get caught
but if you kill somebody that's
something that you need to you know and
that's something that you're going to be
you know spending time for and
thank the lord the lord removed me
before that happened otherwise yeah i
wouldn't be
i'd still be in prison and my cousin he
got 16 years
um or my cousin got he did 13 years and
like whatever
eight years probation my other buddy had
16 years
uh for taking a life or this was the
group of guys i was with they didn't
but this was the group of guys you know
um
and a lot of yeah you can see where that
lifestyle is going correct and you can
see like you know and all of you are
getting caught and pinched and
removed and so where did you
julie come into the picture of this
because did you even know any of this
passed uh very minimally
like i guess so we met how long after
was it that you were out
so so okay so i ended up
getting arrested uh long story short i
did a couple months and then i got
charged from past crimes did another
got six more months then got charged
four years in prison so i just kept
getting charged from past stuff that
caught up to me and
at that point i was like okay you know
the lord was working with me in there
and really
working on me changing me inside jail in
prison
were you reading your bible i was
reading my bible yeah
the lord uh you know there's a lot of
stories within that as well but
you're you're using jail in prison like
interchangeably
there's a difference right correct yeah
there is so so i did a couple months
in jail and then i was out on bond then
they charged me for other crimes i did i
got
charged uh six months so i went to do
that to just before i was gonna get out
oh
got charged for other crimes then i got
four years for prison
and that's when i went to prison um
you know a lot of stories there as well
but after i got out of
jail prison i ended up after the prison
went to a halfway house a couple of them
anyways um after all that
six months maybe after that that's
when i met my wife
so i just get out of prison go ahead so
the halo comes out
the angel wings come out and then you uh
you change your life yeah i mean i was
still when i came out so i went to a
boot camp program
in prison uh to get out early that's one
of the things that you can go and so i
did six months in the boot camp program
um oh that's actually really good
because while i was like
asking the difference between jail and
prison like prison is very intense
compared to
jail yes so my question is like does
prison
work in terms of rehabilitation or like
there's people who
find religion they're not just
christianity but muslim and all of that
there's boot camps does it work
it takes them out of their normal life
it can make it worse they can make it
better yeah
you'll find drugs in prison you'll find
all kinds of negative influence in
prison you'll find people studying the
bible in prison
um so when you played with the boys in
prison did you hurt them too so they
were like don't play with that guy no
no no at that time i mean honestly i i
hung out a lot with the lifers
guys that are in there for life um
and yeah and you know sometimes it's
interesting did god place you there so
that you could see
look at where this road leads look at
all these guys that are here that that
have no way
of option to get out if you continue
down this path you're going to be
with those guys yeah yeah
it was it was an experience and the lord
you know
working on me through that whole thing
okay and when when i got out
um in in boot camp
there were two times i i read my bible
in prison
or in jail prison everything else i had
a lot of time with the bible
the two times that i got to read my
bible in boot camp i got in trouble both
times
they say they give you a half hour
personal time you
almost never get personal time and uh
so when i got out of jail i i still had
uh you know i wanted to keep following
the lord in the things i did
but i did feel weak when i got out you
know
um and right around that time
um i never really got like bad or real
bad
far off um but i did i ended up
i took a job as a bouncer you know what
i'm saying so i did
other things that maybe i wasn't as
extreme but i still was there
and right around that time that's when i
we met at in chicago ish so where did
you meet how did this how did this
transplant and
maybe before we get into the back story
yeah i'd love to hear like kind of your
experience because you said you did you
grew up
not really involved in religion or god
or anything like this so
you know what was your childhood like
what were you into um boy childhood was
a
pretty happy home um on the outside
you know from the most part of it um
there was
you know very little spiritual life um
but i did have a grandparent you know
that was grandparents that were
i want to hang on that i want to hang on
that just for a second because i'm
actually only here because of my
grandmother yeah
like literally the prayers of my
grandmother and i know
absolutely you know there's a lot of
kids that watch our show
and you know we get we get testimonies a
lot from people that just are
impacted by these messages and stuff
like this and and and we do have some
elderly
um grandmothers and things that watch
our show all the time so i just want to
you know throw that out there keep
praying never stop praying because
here is some testimonies of people's
experience as you got prayed out of the
world and into
the fold so yeah yeah and um very much
my mom
from when i was probably almost like
three i think she started to try to get
me into
modeling and different you know kid
i don't know like beauty pageants you
should almost kind of so you went to
that one
at first with the mall you bump up the
steps
i was too shy in the beginning didn't
want anything to do with it but then
around nine
i was like yes i want to go and do
modeling and so we found a local agency
and um my mom started taking me i
started going to chicago
um signed with elite there started doing
some jobs and go sees and you know she
just took a lot of her time
i mean it was amazing the dedication
that my mom gave
um to take me and do all of this and it
was
a dream that just kept progressing that
i started having um
i guess in my teens started kind of
getting
rocky you know i had it i don't know
rebellious
angry going to therapy suicidal
um i ended up going into a
therapy place for a little bit because
of that and um just struggled with a lot
of depression
came out that i was sexually abused as a
child that i had just
blacked that out and um so i had all
that to deal with and then
um just really started getting into
drugs um
eating disorders you know just so many
things started from being around the
modeling industry
history was the definitely the eating
disorders the
drug side that was when i kind of pushed
some of the modeling away and
just got into a really dark place um
so got to the point where you know same
thing it just starts out really small
small things parties whatever even by
myself you know then it just
got to the point where i'm finding
myself in a hotel room
you know almost being attacked and like
how did i get here and
you know using drugs that i never ever
expected that i would and
um yeah getting out by the skin of my
teeth and just
go home my parents like all right are
you ready to do something and i said yes
um
yeah i need help wow so you you had a
point where you came to your parents and
and sort of was honest with them
where you were at what you were involved
in yeah
that's this is the breaking point it was
kind of this this
super dark place where i just i knew
if i keep doing this i am going to end
up being raped i'm going to be
a complete addict um and i saw the
people that i was with
and i'm like i do not want to be that
way so we have two people at their
breaking points coming together
yeah that's interesting yeah yeah you
know i mean i wanna i guess i'm curious
about the modeling industry
um because the public only sees kind of
one side of it they see the pretty
painted
yes you see the the touched up uh i was
uh i was um this house that i was living
in in los angeles
one of the girls that lived in an
apartment close to ours um worked for
cosmopolitan she was a
um worked with a photographer and she
was doing a shoot in venice beach once
and so
she said why don't you come by and check
it out so i remember going in there and
i was hanging out with them and watching
them do the shoot
and it was amazing the girl that that
they were shooting
i mean she was attractive but not like
whoa you know like
i like you right goodness so i was like
yeah she's she's cute or whatever and
they'd bring the photos into the picture
and then i mean it was like real fast
they would yeah stretch and
do stuff and i was like um
you know but but i can imagine that when
your
your value i guess you could say is so
built around this superficial outside
even though you're dark and crumbling on
the inside that's not what they care
about
wow yep and it's it's so hard because
it's um
a continually being picked at yeah
you're being picked up
oh you're too short or you're yes you
need to lose another five pounds or
whatever it is it's just it's so hard
that way whatever self-esteem you go
into that industry with you leave with
nothing yeah
i can remember same thing i did
auditions and stuff when i was in los
angeles and
i mean i was told you know you're ugly
you're this you're that and they just to
your face yeah and you walk out and
you're just like
okay she had a we had a guest on um can
you hear me now
you remember his name um can you hear me
now you mean
uh uh john john no jefferson john
he was saying like in that industry
that's what he would do he actually had
to change his lingo because he was
treating these girls like
objects and i'm going to remember what
you were saying about kind of like
numbing your conscience or
as you keep verbalizing that to someone
yeah they just lose all sense of feeling
and they probably just do whatever you
want them to do
and you start to believe it if this is
what everybody's telling me
and then it's like you might as well
check out you know yes
one of the reasons you probably do that
or at least some people is
they want the they want the adoration
right and what's fascinating is the way
the bible frames that it says
charm is deceitful and beauty is vain
but a woman who fears the lord she shall
be praised
so you get that positive that right
affirmation by following god whereas
you think you're going to get it from
the world and what do they give you
right you get a lot of negative
you know feedback you you read the
beatitudes and it's like what is
important to jesus
is nothing on the outside he didn't say
anything about that he was like i'm
the meek those are the gonna be the
blessed ones that the people that were
kind spirited those are the ones that
you know
that that are valuable in god's eyes so
it's interesting to me to hear
you know someone that's been in that
involved in that industry and so many
people
want that i mean they see it and they go
i would do anything to have what you
have
but then once you're there it's just
emptiness and it's complete
you made a point that a lot of people
don't see the behind the scenes but
there are a lot of people coming out not
just in the fashion industry but um
you know disney movies and things like
that child stars who are coming back and
talking about the trauma but still i
feel like people are like oh
i i get your experience and i empathize
i sympathize but there's so many people
in there that can't possibly be the case
for
everyone right do you have something to
say i can see
how if things could have continued that
possibly that could have happened um i
we had a okay let's see it was a concert
it was like lenny kravitz concert guess
look of the year elite look of the year
and they had a whole
full-blown you know runway show and
concert
and afterwards they just let all the
models that are
a lot of them are underage and you're in
this club that just opened
go free and i'm like my mom was there
not everybody else had their mother
there um you know thank god my mom was
there right
and you just you know that's how all of
that happens you know they just get
sucked in and
nobody's watching them no one's
chaperoning oh yeah you give a 16 year
old
you know alcohol and then no supervision
yeah they're gonna come home with
someone yeah so
yeah did you go to did your parents send
you to any programs for help
that's where you are yes yep i did go
through some mental health
you know hospitals and different things
like that to get some help and
therapy so um and one word of caution
too is pick your
your therapist wisely not everybody is
equal
i did go to one that i think ended up
doing a lot more harm
for probably almost a year and um really
wish that that
hadn't happened because that did yeah
slow things anything
with the brain you have to be cautious
with
you know what i mean because there are
people who can rewire it
basically and and you know highlight
certain things that shouldn't be and
yeah you would think um
movie directors or therapists yeah right
right they push you in so many different
directions right
right so you're recovering but are you
still pursuing that
dream at this point is modeling out of
your life in your life
the recovery that'll a lot of that
happened when i was
a little bit younger and then started
getting back into the modeling as i got
healthier again
um kind of dealt with the bulimia the
eating disorders that had
started happening um dealt with that
quit drugs
um then it was with a boyfriend for
what three years three and a half years
and um
was thinking that that was going to be
my future husband um
but then also feeling like i don't know
if he's really
you know as time went on thinking like i
don't know if this is really the person
that i want to spend the rest of my life
with
and um when we met man
i kind of came to the scene it was right
in the scene of me full out okay i'm
doing my dream now
this is it like i'm just before for it
so you when you went through the drugs
and everything else
and all that um one of the things you
did you did gain some weight
during that time right and then
quitting the drugs and and the blaming
all of that
as a model yep that was ready to pursue
so when you say gain
weight like are you gaining back to a
healthy weight or you're going to make
no i started maybe 30 20 pounds
something yeah
yeah probably like three and then you
started exercising
how many hours a day did you start
exercising preparing for modeling wow
that was a lot at least three you know
three to four hours a day can i ask a
question on the bulimia
and anorexia in your
um you know talking with other models
and things and you know you're obviously
friends with them if you're seeing them
at different shoots and stuff is this a
common thing
oh yes like i mean we're talking like
like most of them
have some kind of eating issues yes yeah
because it's not normal to be
that skinny that thin no and and to be
able to function
and do the shoots and all of that like
you have to
cut weight and you know you're still
hungry
so you end up you have this war of like
okay i really want to be healthy but
then i still love food and
yeah and people just have such a demand
for you to be a certain way that is not
yeah it's unreasonable yeah and on the
flip side of it like you know
especially at that time i think models
now they're allowing
more freedom yeah it's encouraging now
you do see different model types there's
a lot of yeah um
yeah talking about not body shaming
people and stuff you used to only see
like when you go to walmart the in the
girls section you'd always just see
these slim women but now it's like
cookie cutter
yeah now it's more representative of the
simulation the ck1
you know right wasn't there a um a
um victoria's secret model that was like
talking about uh the modeling experience
and why
why we've gotten into skinny women
and they basically said that these men
that were in the fashion
industry that were sort of these um
linchpin
kind of type of men they're all gay and
they would like boys and so then they
were picking girls that had
boy frames basically and then that just
kind of took on because
yeah back in the olden days the more
voluptuous the woman was is like that
was attractive you know you see those
paintings and those women are you know a
little bigger
you know i look at i look at two you
know and one of the things that you know
the lord has
you know uh brought healing with so i've
seen
you know drugs i've seen all that you've
seen that too and i've seen people come
off of that and like the eating disorder
and from my perspective
that was more difficult than any type of
drug coming off of
your relationship with food it's a vital
part of your life it's
everyday choice and it's um yeah
and it's everywhere too it's everywhere
yeah it's every family function every
gathering is
oh it's there's no stigma to it i mean
it's not like here have a donut they're
not thinking like oh it's like giving
the crack to somebody
yeah it's acceptable before we move on
and go though
what would you say to somebody if they
were watching this
maybe they have an eating disorder
because i think this is more common than
we can even
comprehend what kind of steps can you
even make to
to begin to get out of it know your
trigger points
no you know okay am i too tired am i
pushing myself too much is there too
much stress right now that i'm going to
end up
going down this path like you kind of
have to know
yourself and be real and honest with
yourself because a lot of times we lie
to ourselves and that's how we end up
doing this cycle over and over again
yeah and um also having an
accountability partner so
talk about it share light on it yes
because yeah people know in your life
that you can trust that are
healthy minded um that can help you
because that's
really you know evil thrives in darkness
yes and and i remember when when i kind
of first came to the realization like
i'm a drug addict
like that was i remember first kind of
just saying i have a problem
um it was really through talking about
it that helped me get away from it
i remember the first time i ever said
anything um to my family members and
that was the hardest thing coming out of
my mouth like i have a
problem and um through that recognition
of saying yes
i need help i think was able to get me
away from that absolutely community is
so important i was listening to a
podcast by
jeanette she was um on icarly she's one
of the actress on icarly and she was in
like sam and kat on disney channel
anyway she was saying it's not just uh
isolated or like a
really personal thing bulimia and
anorexia it's actually a competition
between
the actresses and like the anorexics
look down on the bulimia
i don't bulimics because they're like
you know you have no self-control like
we're able to abstain
um so she just had to take a step back
from the industry completely remove
herself from that and focus on herself
go to the therapies because just being
in that environment alone
itself was triggering it's like i'm out
of the game because i'm deciding to do
what's right for myself
isn't isn't that sad because it seems
like you know we got ourselves in this
mess because of a food
right somebody ate a piece of fruit that
they shouldn't have eaten
i mean when we talk about heaven first
thing we talk about is we're going to go
up there and have this feast right
food is such an intimate intimate
um part of our human experience and and
um you know
i'm looking forward to eating absolutely
crazy
[Laughter]
so you're you're kind of you know
experiencing this coming out of this
you like how did this converge here
true because that's two different worlds
yeah yeah
we ended up meeting in chicago at
modeling convention he was there with a
friend as
yeah what were you doing
[Laughter]
well uh yeah so she was uh more serious
about it
me um it was just a quirky thing i heard
a thing on radio
me and my brother went to it and then if
you pass they give you a ticket to go to
a weekend thing
and then i went to weekend thing in
minnesota
and uh i mean it was just crazy because
i just think i had no shoots no
nothing no portfolio all these people
did i brought a body i said you took a
photography class right
yes yeah like all right let's go so we
we drove up there we stopped at a rest
area i threw on different clothes snap
snap snap snaps
okay let's go boom wow and i pictures
that you like literally just took
hilarious so then when we went up there
um i remember we went up there at the
radisson
in 26 story rotating restaurant so i
remember that
so we went on up there and uh as me and
my buddy were up there
um a lot of i had to go to walgreens
they had to make the things
and open up he's making his head shots
at walgreens
so anyways after that we go to this
restaurant and here
as we're eating there's all the agents
and
all the different people that were in
this other thing well me
i'm not afraid to talk to people so i'm
just like hey
you got those things let's go ask them
you know because usually you can pay
somebody and they'll go through your
photos and pick out which ones are good
that you're going to show the agents
well so i just went on over there and
started talking they're like oh you got
your phone let's check it out so that i
brought my stuff they're like oh well
these are really good now my buddy's
there i'm there i'm trying not to bust
down laughs
they're like wow these are really good
i'm just you know so anyways
went there and uh you know it was a fun
uh they says hey do you want to go to uh
california osbrink i don't know
i know i actually was uh wrecked by
osborne oh okay okay so they said you
want to go to california i'm like yeah
sure you know whatever
and uh i became friends with the guy he
says in two weeks i'm going to chicago
another one i just think this is the
greatest thing though like oh man
you know there's everybody all women
around there it's just a good time
so anyways uh we went down to chicago
and there were 1300 people so the guy
gives you
you know it's like a cattle run that's
how it just makes me think a cow run you
know
trying to get that one gig yeah correct
so you put on your loud belt
so i'm just there as a guest okay okay
so as i'm driving down there i was
listening to how to remember people's
names
okay so because as i'm listing this
thing driving down the chicago three
hour drive
i say okay well i gotta put this into
practice so out of probably about 100
people that i first met i remembered
maybe 97
98 people wow so she was one of the
people that that i met now i don't have
a ton of memory from her from that
weekend i just there's so much going on
but we do have a picture downtown
chicago and i did have my hand on her
leg
but uh so from that weekend that that
group of hundred
there was probably 15-ish people that
got together
two weeks later that you organized in
grand rapids michigan
so she's all serious like okay what
agents have you talked to what
you know talking all business i'm still
just hanging out you know
i'm trying to find a roommate i'm like
who's moving to new york
i picked up a gale in madison um and
then i drove over to grand rapids
michigan so i
i came with a gal there and we didn't
really talk to like the very last day
so you know um there are a lot of guys
that were you know
trying to hit on you but uh i just kind
of like you know
set back the biggest impact
what happened so we're in this hotel you
know you're thinking okay
your nose in the air kind of snooty type
people somebody spilled
some champagne on the ground here she
gets down her hands and knees is
cleaning it
that was the most powerful thing
right there she can clean up
no i was just like wow that's like
cleaning ever since
but that was the most important like wow
that's pretty cool you know yeah
and so we talked a little bit but you
know i don't know her she doesn't know
me
or the gal that i brought says hey my
photographer is looking for your look
want to do a full shoot with you
everything else you should come
she's 18 years old just turned 18 a
month ago or before
writes a parents or note that night
don't do this at home kids
write some parents a note that like
going to wisconsin blah blah blah so
that's what they wake up to
well it was funny because in the in the
note it was something like i feel like i
need to do this like
you know like there was a calling or
something i don't know this week
you were only 18 at this point yeah and
already been through the rehab and all
this stuff and yeah
wow wow it's a full life at 18. yeah so
but i don't want to miss that point you
know what drew you to her because a lot
of
a lot of people are obsessed with that
outer like i'm looking for a husband let
me make sure all of this
is good to go you were looking at what
that that was the
biggest thing that struck me like wow
that's really cool because that just
shows humility
like there's something there besides the
shell you know because yeah okay you all
pray everybody you know whatever
but wow there's something there there's
substances
i'm sitting there wondering because this
is almost a metaphor
in your own life though here she is
cleaning up a mess
what have you just been through a mess
and it's like so speaks to your
situation
you see somebody who's willing to get
down there
and clean something up and i don't know
i'm just it's just powerful
she still cleans my mess but i also
think it's really neat that you know
here you have this
like seriously this guy's been in a lot
of trouble
and and but you got a good heart i mean
you can just see like you know
you would you would think that you're
just going to be surface superficial and
this and that and it's like what
what what attracts you together
is is really something um beautiful like
that you would even appreciate a value
like that
and you would even have a value like
that that is kind of a cool story
and i think a lot of that you know comes
back to prayer you know what i'm saying
like you know like uh
your grandfather and your grandmother
and you know it looks my parents
prayer prayer prayer you know i know my
mom's constantly praying for you know
all those things
i think that is you know i just say
we're here because of the grace of god
and the prayers and then that we're from
you know our parents and you know it's
amazing when we get to heaven you will
just see the orchestration that happens
to get you in the same room together you
know what i mean
beautiful i mean the timing just if any
little thing oh you didn't come or
whatever you didn't come to grand rapids
i mean so many different things could
have all been different
but scott had a reason for what was the
pickup line when you saw her
yeah i don't remember the line because i
like there was so much i spilled
something over here
so because we even that was that was
saturday
and uh we really didn't talk even much
until sunday that was just something
that like
hit me and you know maybe chewed in my
mind for a while
but uh so she wrote a parenthood note
that night
you know and then i took them uh i took
it was nicole it was you um and then
lenny
you know so i i dropped them off in
madison a couple hours away from my
house for four days and then they did
this
you know she did the shoot and
everything else then i went to pick her
up and we spent
three days together and that's why i say
when
so in madison that's when i met the
um agent that was going to take you know
that ended up taking me to
new york and all that so it was like at
the same time so yeah so things are
starting to get lined up for you
right yeah everything's starting to line
up that way and you're just there for
fun it seems like yeah yeah
yeah yeah just seemed like a good idea
i just go four states away no problem
but yeah so then it was you know so then
yeah photo shoot lineup you know all
that stuff in medicine that was four
days
then i pick her up we spent three days
together
so it was the end of the third day was
it
yeah it was the end of the third day we
were talking and
remember i had this calling of ministry
since i was a kid and i knew it
even though it wasn't like you know
where i wanted to be
i just i had that on my heart and so i'm
thinking okay when i get my head out of
the bucket
okay you know you got model youth
minister
model youth minister i'm trying to like
mesh them together they don't really
flow well you know
and uh then you shared
yeah i had different times of
church and different things um where i
just felt like this calling for
being missionary or for wow you know
orphans or just
there was something there that i knew i
wanted to
want to serve in some way go ahead well
one of your thoughts too
was hey you know i'll get famous as a
model do this i'll do that and then i
can help
you you don't want to how we think in
our head
yeah i figured i was gonna get out get
there make a name for myself be able to
help these girls with
eating disorders people coming out of
drug issues that kind of thing
and that never would have happened i
know correct
scenario so i have a question for you
guys did you ever hear this voice
earlier on before you chose to work in
ministry did you hear this voice yeah
like
you're saying that yeah i'm thinking
about it too because even
even like during the times when i was
singing
songs of blasphemy like i hated
christianity at some point in time but
there was uh i can think back i'm like
why now i'm like
really confused about it but i know that
there was a time when i was like
telling that guy i did music with like
what if we made a twist at the end of
this and it's somehow like a christian
song order because it was really mocking
the crucifixion but
i knew that that was a little out there
and it wouldn't be like
you know mainstream media type thing so
i was like what if at the end
it's like the roman soldier like you
know converts or something
and i and i always in my in the back
back there somewhere i was like i always
wanted to make
cool sounding christian music because
christian music always sounded cheesy
and corny i was like
i want to make something sounds cool
even though i wasn't a christian was
really
walking totally away from christianity
yeah there was little things like that
in my mind i really wonder how many
people go through that
i can remember being a kid and being
like no god i don't want to be a
preacher
no i don't no i'd rather you know i'm
going to go to hollywood you know and it
was like
this voice in the back of my mind and i
wonder if everybody somewhat experiences
that old
you were saying that too how old was i
oh i was probably
12 13. i remember when when it started
having thoughts like that and so
yeah i remember like three distinct
times three distinct
age age ranges i remember being about
four five six
and specifically praying uh for wisdom
it's like i know this story about
solomon in the bible that guy had wisdom
as like if you get wisdom you can handle
anything in life you can make money you
can do what you need to do
takes care of it so being a little kid i
remember
at 10 i got baptized by the time i hit
11 i knew god i made a promise that i
was going to be an evangelist
because that's what he put on my heart
and i remember after i got married
that i needed to go into ministry like
god was telling me that specifically
and that there were three things in my
life that had to change
so and he made those happen in the order
that they were told
wow so yeah god does work on people's
hearts from an early age
but i think he talks to everybody
absolutely
there's a calling but in my experience i
think training also has a lot to do with
exactly
because so i grew up adventist and i
grew up in a very
caribbean community specifically so
you're hearing
um mission stories in sabbath school
you're being put at the front of the
church to preach and like
like when you're six you know
so um yeah definitely training and of
course um what was going on in my home
watching maranatha mission stories so
then when i had my interest in
photography videography it was kind of
molded towards that
missionary not necessarily preaching but
wanting to serve god right so it was
like a mix of blender
somehow be involved in his work exactly
so you guys are starting to feel this
and and now
so uh yeah so the third day
um that's why i said it was about three
days of the sabbath
i thought yeah it wasn't yeah so one two
three so thursday
friday sabbath so the sabbath afternoon
um it was just you and me that were at
the house
and uh you know we're sharing this stuff
she's saying yeah you know i want to do
i'm like wow that's really cool you know
maybe there's something there
as we're sharing this the lord is
working on both of our hearts
and uh we prayed and asked god into our
hearts
let's pray so we prayed we asked god
into our hearts
as soon as we said amen i'm like look at
me yeah
she's like oh no not now she knew i knew
and i asked her to marry me you know
it's not how you yeah you're 18
yeah i mean it was the most deep
repetitive yeah oh moving prayer
ever i mean you're just and i know it's
not running
this is my bonus story because you guys
are here for some model thing
the topic of religion kind of comes out
it's like it turned real fast
yeah and so so
you know you know how the devil works
though when you start setting your feet
or your eyes in the right direction it's
like watch how easy i can make this
oh yeah
so we you know we prayed ask out into
our hearts right every second then
she knew i knew you know i asked her to
marry me she said yes
wow and um so the only way to make it
work is to put god first
yeah we had different you know because
of our upbringings very different idea
of what that means what does it mean to
put god first i'm like okay sure he had
no problem
keep in mind so her your parents don't
know anything yet
so did they just throw a modeling
machine
so and and and you know we had to go
back
and tell the gentleman that you're worth
for three and a half years as well
so there's a lot of the dynamics there
um
so anyways we took a ferry over because
they're michigan
wisconsin michigan you took the ferry
over so we took the ferry over we called
your parents says hey
we gonna come on over we gotta talk to
you they're like we
and he's like that guy that was that
weekend he's coming with two and so
they're just like
trouble okay wow okay
boys and girls don't do this yes
so when we got there i remember going
into the basement
for one don't say that you just came out
of prison a few months ago yeah that's
not an applause
but here i am hey we're getting married
i just got out of prison
did i mention the drugs but i'm good now
but uh so yeah i mean you know her poor
parents
is 50 waking up to the note just the
week before it's just like man you know
loading it
wow um but anyway so yeah so that there
was that dynamic going on
then that was the net 99
so the first year had the worldwide uh
you know
bible study basically and so you went
you you actually came back for that that
was like about a month
something like that and go ahead so each
each night
each night i mean night after night i
was just
dumbfounded i'm like why didn't anybody
ever tell me this anymore how is this
how do people not know this like it's
just clicking
oh my word every night every night i was
convicted and every night i was just
like yes lord yes lord like this is just
amazing i just felt like this whole new
world
of understanding of god's word was
finally open to me and i'm like this is
incredible we need to tell people
like this people need to know in here
and it was just so on fire for god
and you know shackles are just being
broken every night just to
surrender and um it finally i think
you'd like you said it was the what was
the thing that we went to
the muscle guys oh that was so yeah so
you went to
you went to the one month bible study so
the lord's pulling that out
then your agent your new agent you go to
new york you have elite you have ford
you have all the
agencies that you're going through now
you're making plans with nicole the gal
that i picked up
going on over there to do work so
there's all these dynamics that are
taking place
and um was it a bit of a serious
internal struggle for you
i mean obviously you're you're you're
gaining an understanding of god and sort
of this big picture
christian you know right right and then
all of a sudden the world is enticing
you with
me everything it has to offer and at
first i didn't realize that that's what
was happening
you know because satan's really sly with
that and but it did
take prayer and continued study
and god just really using his spirit to
speak to me and say hey but you know
open your eyes here this is what's
happening
can i ask you a question can you be a
good
solid christian in that business is that
is that a possibility for somebody to to
get involved in
you know that man
that's a very heavy question because i
mean
because we get asked this about about
the entertainment industry all the time
i want to be there i know daniel went
and lived in the occultic
civilization and he was able to remain
faithful
right maybe maybe the maybe the more
solid question is
can you stay in that industry
and state can your christianity grow
because there are probably people that
are
there that have genuine hearts are
following christ to the night that they
have
but then new light comes in and now it
conflicts with
your circumstance your job i would
definitely
you know it's i actually funny i had a
girl come to me
probably i don't know how many years ago
now maybe seven years ago
she was going and doing like espn type
um
wanted to be more of the broadcaster but
it was also doing modeling and really
getting into it and
had some big opportunities and she came
to me and i
just really gave her some counsel i said
you are so gifted and talented
don't throw it away for the world like
god wants to use that he gave you all
those gifts and those talents for a
reason
wow i don't think that's it and so we
prayed and i you know i said but
it has to come down to what you and god
because nobody else can tell you what to
do
and um but you really need to be honest
with yourself and with the lord and
listen to what he's calling you to do
and she decided not to
and she's used those gifts and talents
for god in so many amazing ways so
that's really
really cool to see um so i think that's
why i'm excited about your idea with
building this uh
christian creative mecca because we have
all these young people with all these
talents and it just seems like the world
is the place that they can go the only
place to do it
right you have to provide a place i
think for people to use their talents
in a protected godly you know
faith-based
way absolutely yeah there's parameters
on that you know
i think that uh you know we we can use
our creativity god is very creative
and he's put that bug inside of us um
but i think
also it's it's what are our motives by
doing that you know if you're
if you're using beauty to entice people
into an unholy lifestyle
right there's a problem i think there's
a difference there's a difference
between wanting to do it and being
called to do it there's people like you
know the people in the bar need to hear
the gospel and then they put themselves
into that
environment under the guise of the
justification of i need to reach these
people
but no god has his special person that
he can reach those people it doesn't
have to be you because you feel like
that's next thing you know you end up
being influenced instead of being the
influencer
right yeah and you know as
that continues so we're engaged about a
year um
but it was what like maybe six months
six nine months for the modeling stuff
yeah
so me i didn't feel like okay this is
what god
wants us to do and so her parents
everybody i mean since she was little
like all the energy time money
everything you know her friends
all this is going on this is your career
and i'm just like i don't think you know
so there's these dynamics that are
taking place
and then uh yeah after that
you know so you went to new york you did
all that
with agents and all that and then they
want you to
move there and the the big thing was
when you got uh barcelona spain the
night before
the night before you got the call we
went to uh
uh not strong men power team power
so went to the power team and it was the
fifth night they had five nights
describe what the power team is here
yeah different generation
oh yes okay so power team were these
just massively strong guys like world's
strongest guys they take
they take frying pans roll them up and
burritos
yeah yeah or big events or whatever i
mean these guys are
you know just like a phone book like
this is like impossible possible yeah
it's kind of a interesting dynamic
because you're watching it and you're
like
power god you're like i don't know about
that dude you're massive
of course you can bend the crowbar look
at yours i mean yeah
the stuff they do was just crazy but
they share their testimonies
and their faith and yeah yeah it's it's
powerful
it spoke to you yeah it spoke to me so
that night
it was okay you decided this is not what
god wants you to do yeah that was and
what did you do after that
yeah that night i just felt like the the
calling of god like
you have to put the world behind you and
um
you have an idol in the way and um that
idol was my portfolio
all my all my work all my pictures
everything that i
years and years had encompassed into
this little from
this black book yeah and um so god said
you know you gotta
get rid of it and so i said okay lord
i'll i'll do it you know i'll do
whatever it
whatever you want me to do i'm willing
and so
trembling hands you know tearing up
those pictures
i even burned clothes too and i knew it
was my ticket if i didn't do that i was
so weak
spiritually as a new christian that was
my ticket in
because you have to have those pictures
you know it's like you if you don't have
that you're not able to work
question though how did you or can you
explain to someone who may be watching
who might be skeptical how did she know
she was doing it for god and not her
fiance
um yeah that was a big question too
because
there's a lot of you know family friends
like what are you doing
you're doing this for this guy like they
think oh this major change has got you
know
justin and not god and i'm like no it's
um i knew my heart i guess i mean
you know i had that conviction over and
over and over again
and just that truth brought to me eyes
opened
it's like i knew it was the lord i mean
there's no way that i would do this for
him or anyone else and so for me it was
just it was the power of god that
gave me the strength to even do that
because i couldn't do it myself you
can't
serve two masters no you cannot serve
two masters i could not
even have the strength to do that myself
and um it was his calling to
to free me and really when i did that
there was
just this release i mean i felt like
shackles taken off of me this weight
lifted off of me that i knew
i didn't even know it was there right um
so
it definitely was an idol there was yeah
sometimes those things take dramatic
measures to basically distance yourself
and
yeah change i mean you you have to
remove yourself
from anything associated with that right
and i know i know some people think oh
that's so extreme you know
it's about clarity though yeah yeah i i
mean
i i can remember movies was my idol and
i collected them
and and i can remember destroying them
and and you know thinking like you know
i paid all this money
can i sell them like i have to destroy
them
but there's something psychologically um
profound about
the idea of just saying i'm breaking
down this
idol so i like that you recognized that
and you were responding yeah and you
break it down you don't pass it on to
someone
else right you don't want to sit here
take my used title
wow and then the next day next morning i
get the phone call
that i have been waiting for my whole
life dreaming
yeah yes
it was definitely that two war it was
just this war
you know wow that had been accumulating
over these past months
and um my mom called and she's like this
is it you got
you got it you got it you're going to
barcelona spain three months and after
that
they said that you'll be traveling the
world that's it and um
i did not call my agent back i didn't
have the strength to talk to her and
said mom and i had to tell my mom what
i'm like i'm not going and
you know of course you can imagine her
response she had no idea
what are you talking about you're crazy
yes of course you're going what are you
saying
so now you have the added pressure of
your parents going no no no no we
invested
how many years of driving you around
this and that and paying for this and
that
parents friends you're throwing your
life away yes exactly
you're going to regret this you know all
these things oh wow
but even perfect timing with age because
it's not like you're 14 and they're like
no we're going like you don't have a say
in this you're not
able to make the decision wow
so was there a moment of like oh no what
did i just
right full regret um i don't know if
there was ever
full regret i think there was definitely
times of
thoughts of like oh wow you know look at
what i could have had maybe but you know
but still even in those thoughts it was
like no
no that's so false like look at what i
have now
like look what and god promised me
actually that night when i did
my portfolio he said i have something in
store for you
that is better than anything the world
could ever give you
and that was his promise to me that
night and um
he's fulfilled it through the years
there's nowhere else you know it's
not been an easy road i was going to say
it's happiness ever after right
bliss
[Laughter]
i mean i'm sure this is intense
at this stage you're public enemy number
one from everybody
she knows yes yes yes i was pretty much
disowned
for a while still public enemy number
one or have people come around
have you been able to change their view
based on how you have approached them
how you've ministered to them i would
say yes
i think it you know her family yeah her
family
of course yeah public enemy number one
hated my guts
now you're getting religion you know
they think oh you're joining a culture
you meet this guy you're just like
everything
yeah they thought i went off the deep
end correct
but um you know you go into the corner
of the street and say hey i want to do
drugs or drink you hear people yeah yeah
yeah
yeah the signs are people go i just want
a dollar for beer you are throwing money
out of them
i gave my life to jesus are you sure you
want to do that yeah
are you sure that's the right thing i
don't know
you know crazy yeah but
time time was the telltale you know i
think that's what's
one everybody's hearts just being able
to see
what god has done with all of it over
the years
and they have changed wow and uh yeah
now
there's another small detail here in all
of
this that i'm sure that the grandparents
are very thankful for
yeah how many children do you have
yes we have nine nine nine
i'm sorry did i say that again it was
nine nine like
eight girls and one boy right in the
middle wow
[Music]
i mean your quivers are full yeah i
never expected it no
we didn't come from large families um
never
planned on having no children wow so can
you speak to how god is providing for
you
because i mean so you're out of prison
so that's
probably it and i construction so
i mean that's you know we lived in a
two-bedroom apartment for 11 years
um and there's a lot more stories
i was in a wheelchair too yeah i know
there's like i say there's lots of like
that's another show
but yeah so i was in a wheelchair too
during a time
um shortly after we got married and we
weren't planning on having kids the
first five years
ten days before one year anniversary
here comes our first kid she didn't
listen
but uh anyways so yeah and then after
that then i had the arthritis
for about two years and uh i'm pretty
good in a wheelchair if you guys you
said
bad oh yeah uh yeah so i could have it
tomorrow the rest of my life i could
never have it again
they don't know so it comes and goes i
have a gene that
uh it's an autoimmune thing that you
could have a reaction
you could not no wow so um so yeah so
you're right man everything about you is
intense he's like all right like we have
the baby
let's go all out
so yeah and yeah there's a lot packed in
and we'll be 21 years this october
[Music]
but there's a lot packed into
like even the first five years of our
life yes yeah yeah so
so you guys are like getting married
getting together and then you know god
is really
developing you down the road like you
know
how is that happening with your family i
mean is it just sort of
you have to change all your friends and
now you're in this whole new direction
like what's happening in your lives
wow maybe maybe maybe to speak to this
part because our
we've heard you say many times ministry
ministry ministry ministry
so how is it that you are ministering to
people today
so my number one ministry is my wife my
number
well god my relationship with god then
my wife my second ministry is my
children
and then my third ministry is anybody
that the lord brings into our influence
so that's kind of like the core of of
our ministry
um which right now includes a lot of
neighboring
children yeah they we always collect
we're on vacation
and we actually brought in another kid
because we don't have enough yeah right
yeah we have an extra seat up the
intensity come on so wait a minute
how are you even moving these people
around i mean
we're talking this is 12 people yeah
well uh
yeah there isn't even a vehicle that you
can do
well we drive it sounds really crazy we
drive a freightliner shuttle bus
so you get yeah the it makes sense you
know
thank you put your luggage on to the
back of it yeah so it was a 21 passenger
with a luggage
compartment in back a large luggage now
it's a
we got two tables so that can fit four
in each table we got two queen beds a
twin bed we got refrigerator
inverter a few other things or whatever
and that's how we
can get a picture up for people to see
like that'll be so yeah we could
probably get it we could probably get a
picture
i mean when you get a hotel is it like
we'll just take the
yeah so the shuttle bus we could sleep
10 so everybody can sleep except me
yeah you don't need to sleep i mean it's
only obvious
so does it get easier the more children
you have
what yeah interesting no i mean the
older ones like how many is your horse
how old is your oldest
she's 19. yeah she's she's 22 she's 19.
she's
almost 20 years old and your youngest is
two and a half
oh wow wow that's a spring so we had
yeah so we had our oldest
uh she's 19. and then there's a
five-year gap
and then we had eight kids from 14 years
old to two years old
she's like the third parent huh yes
probably the top three oh yeah honestly
the kids can all help
i talk to a woman when we're starting to
have a lot of children and like how am i
going to do this how do you homeschool
how do you
you know there was just so much that i
had to ask this lady and she said
the number one thing that stuck with me
she said i every day
am working myself out of a job that is
my goal
i am here to help encourage
and train and make them self-sufficient
and so that's been my take okay that's
something i can do every day
and so i've done that and it has paid
off and
so now the kids can run the house if
they need to i can be gone
and not have to worry too much so i mean
if you have enough kids there's somebody
mowing your lawn there's somebody
cooking
oh my goodness there's somebody
kept fighting over there what did your
brother do now
what's the story about the bowl the
scripture about the bowl
oh oh um mark grunger laugh your way to
better marriage
yes yes and it fits it's
uh where the ox is
where the ox is the trough is full but
much strength uh comes by the
strength of an ox something like that
paraphrase
not quoted but yeah basically you gotta
ask there's zach's poo
there's gonna be a lot of ox what a lot
of strength comes
from that and that's same with the
family there's a lot of things going on
but it's such it's a richness but i
think that's really neat because
it's it's so uncommon in our culture
today to have that
i mean do you get people are you mormon
um
have you ever left him anywhere oh wow
accidentally okay
cut moving
actually do they know your story oh yes
they've heard us
share it yes they know our story
yeah they know our story um yeah
because i was just listening fascinating
story oh my goodness
wow but um the verse came to mind is it
proverbs train up a child in the way he
should go yeah and when he's
old he will not depart from it and you
were saying you had all these this head
knowledge it may not necessarily have
been in your heart but look when it came
out
right and and um you know i hear people
like you know what's the point you know
it's just in their head like they're not
making any changes but no like
god can use that seed germinate it and
blossom and then
the way that you never even expected it
he can rope you back into his love
and that's just so important when you
walk with god you never know what he's
gonna do every day is an adventure i
feel like because you just never know
what
i mean we're here now like i'm not
planning this you know
god's office and it's awesome it's a
blessing um yeah you drove ten hours a
day
they live in wisconsin okay this is
[Laughter]
yeah it really is and and i think um for
me it's just such a blessing to hear how
you know you're a bit of a train wreck
in the beginning here
you know yeah and and the ending i got a
good wife yes yes
and now what a beautiful experience that
you guys are now having and i'm sure
your story is not done
you're still writing it you're still you
know having some ups and downs and
things like that but
you know how has this impacted your
faith in god
this experience yeah growth i mean you
know knowing that
the scripture i hold on he has begun a
good work in us
amen he will finish it it's not justin
has begun a good workout
right now he has begun a good workout
and he finished so i hold on to that
promise
he started that he put that in my heart
when i was little
you know what i'm saying and like you
say in every one of our hearts it very
well could be argued you know what i'm
saying
he put that in the heart for a reason
and he will finish it
when we surrender to him that's right
that's right well you guys
absolutely sound like amazing godly
parents
training up your children in those ways
instilling in them the values that you
have now
you know built in your family and you
now are putting
many children out into the world as many
little
you know uh workers for god and so you
know
how is your family involved or
interested in sort of
you know ministry or anything like that
yeah i mean uh so at home we do a few
different things
um we do like bible studies and
different things there and then the
children part of
you know so we home school so um we do a
lot of different things
in our home life um to connect
relationally spiritually
but uh once the kids turn 18 i want them
to go to a specific
um like evangelism school or three or
four months school to really
have that experience and that's the
culmination of like
it for me that's the culmination of our
homeschooling we give them the
groundworks we let them know the
scripture
you know not just on the table but no
the word of god where is it found how
did we look into it how to use it you
know
so do everything i can to teach them
that and then uh
give them that experience and that's the
culmination of as a parent okay good
you know what i'm saying you you have
your wings now
and i will support you and guide you in
wherever the lord brings you so
that's so fascinating like do you have a
few minutes after the show to do a post
show about parenting like that would be
sure that would be great that would be
great that'd be great yeah
because i'm assuming you both are
experts in the subject
[Laughter]
yeah i want to definitely hear a little
bit more so that'd be good to save for
for the post show and stuff like that
but
all right thank you guys for blessing us
with your story and
i praise god that he's brought you
through and out of that
and uh now you know sometimes he lets us
go through these experiences so that we
can minister to other people
i mean you know depression suicide those
kind of things are
are are something that i believe we
don't talk about enough
and i know that many people experience
those things and
sometimes like the modeling industry we
only see the outside
we don't see what's going on on the
inside and so
you know and in your case like you know
just to have a child that
that maybe is wayward and and you're
thinking he's
he's lost he's gone he's done like i'm
gonna give up on this
but to to know that you had people
praying for you and has brought you
through that experience and now look you
you guys are
you know in your right mind
have an amazing blessing family and and
uh thank you for
you know sharing that story with us we
hope you guys were
definitely blessed by this uh like we
said we're gonna keep this conversation
going a little bit over on uh our
patreon page
so if you don't know what that is check
out our patreon page we we do like to do
some extra content
dive into it a little bit deeper or or
just share some fun details
but thank you guys for watching and uh
you know we hope that you guys learned
something from this story
that you know god is doing all he can to
reach
everyone all the time and when we get to
heaven
it will be amazing to hear all the
different unique stories
of how god brought us out of this sinful
world
and into his glory well we'll catch you
guys next week
have a great time
[Music]
i am the god of the new
i world anime i love it i mean i can't
watch
enough of this the duelist who they say
can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern from parents the
death note is derived from a japanese
animated show the girl told authorities
she got the idea from a cartoon network
show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
um
[Music]
you